the story of vernafun brown
you know and the fascination with
rockets and
this will
you know enlarge something in the world
and here he is he's an ss officer he's
working around slave labor
and then but his rocket then gets
compressed into the the western world or
the american world and
basically
launches us to the moon and we forget
about the sauce how the sausage was made
uh originally
what can you talk about him a little bit
more because he's such a fascinating
character
because he so he's he was a nazi
but he was also an american and it had
such a grand impact on on
both
and like is there's this uncomfortable
fact that he's you know
one of the central figures that gave
birth to the american space application
efforts yeah he's an interesting figure
fascinated in a kind of a tunnel vision
way with
space flight he makes these beautiful
rockets already beginning in the 20s
early 30s
ends up for a while at panamunda using
slave labor to build
uh v2 engines and and so forth like that
i i remember going to panamunda
where people have actually tracked the
flights of aborted v2
rockets and found some of these
beautiful beautiful old engines
just the most like works of art these
these these engines used to rain terror
uh on on the british
it's interesting because in that same
spot i was hunting for amber baltic
amber because i'm a stone collector
and among the amber collectors there
there's a
famous story of the the panama to burn
it's called because they find yellow
phosphorus they think it's amber they
put it in their pocket and then it dries
out and then explodes and creates this
big burn
uh
burn on their legs
but the whole nazi regime is is full of
things like that it's full of these
scholars who get twisted
into a mindset and
it's also important to realize that
people didn't often see what was coming
and we look back and we say how could
you x y or z but
before the holocaust there's not the
holocaust
there are versions of it but
things get on a new meaning get a new
meaning in light of subsequent events
and there's a
entire propaganda machine that makes it
easier for you to
to to hold the narrative in your head
even if you kind of intuitively know
there's something really wrong here
because of the propaganda you can kind
of convince yourself to be able to sleep
at night
you